un caddie virtuel pour révéler son
potentiel de golfeurs voilà ce que
promet et l'obr dit une application pour
mobiles présentés ici sur le parcours du
golf
isabella plaisir le mode de
fonctionnement est simple dès la
première partie le joueur pourra
bénéficier de conseils pour optimiser
son plan de jeu pour des tarifs allant
de 4 euros 99 à 100 euros par an donc là
pour le trou numéro un
on me dit de jouer le driver donc on ne
me frustre pas trop un fer 5
un gap wedge ensuite une approche peu
jay 85 % de chances d'atteindre mon
objectif et ensuite je n'ai plus qu'à
remplir la carte en disant driver faire
singapour est du nombre de putts et
simplement ça me sert ça ne change pas
la routine habituelle 20 golfeurs qui a
l'habitude d'avoir une carte de score et
un crayon dans la poche
aucun appareil de mesure n'est
nécessaire mais l'application est en
mesure de calculer la difficulté d'un
coup en fonction des aptitudes du joueur
afin de déterminer quelles sont les
probabilités statistiques que vous
atteignez telle grille nous que vous
atteignez tel fairway ou que vous
puissiez
avoir le bonheur de réussir un birdie
sur tel ou tel trou à l'ensemble des
téléphones devraient être prochainement
compatible et de nouvelles
fonctionnalités interdite en compétition
sont déjà en cours de développement